my co-founder major has a phrase he says
which I love which is that all the
advice in the world sums up to zero
there's very few people who knows
exactly what's right for you and
ultimately it's okay if you're the only
one in the world who sees the value of
what you're building
chipper is a mobile based Financial
platform that is targeted towards people
living in Africa and Out of Africa
offering a whole Suite of financial
products and services from cross-border
payments to investing in
cryptocurrencies and U.S fractional
stocks to issuing Visa debit cards and
also offering a bunch of business to
business solutions
me and my co-founder majored we both
grew up in Africa I was born and raised
in Uganda major was born and raised in
Ghana and we both saw firsthand how
difficult it was for people to send
money from one person to another but
also from one country to another within
Africa and for us that was a clear space
that we thought we could contribute to
so when we met in college it was
something that brought us together in
terms of trying to solve that problem
we've raised over 300 million dollars
today in Venture Capital the company
valued at over 2 billion dollars as of
the last round we have over 400
employees web officers in New York
Nigeria
Uganda Ghana and we're expanding in more
areas as we increase our operational
base
my first inspiration to do anything
entrepreneurial came from my parents
both self-employed my entire life they
worked together both as farmers and in
other Ventures my dad is a computer
Scientist by training so he has an I.T
Farm but there wasn't really a computer
science Industry in Uganda so in many
ways he couldn't explore the the limits
of his own ambition in that sense but he
instilled a great sense of
Entrepreneurship in me watching him and
my mom walk together and for me the idea
of being able to solve a problem every
day was more exciting than anything I
could think of so I knew my entire life
I wanted to do something on my own that
was important that you could build a big
business around
[Music]
we launched in our fast Market in late
2018. in the beginning we thought we
might have some demand for our product
we didn't expect it to be this much we
also didn't expect it to be this
difficult in terms of how many hurdles
you have to jump through to to make
something work the most challenging part
I think has been
not knowing what we don't know you know
you're running too many walls many that
you don't anticipate you're running to
so whatever you think it's going to take
a cost to get something done it usually
takes some costs three times or four
times as much in the very early days
that's in the first one
two years the biggest challenge is just
being able to attract people to invest
and care about what we're doing as a
serious Venture a lot of people on the
surface looked at us is something that
was philanthropic because it dealt with
Africa they didn't see a big opportunity
there they didn't understand the market
and so they didn't really pay us much
mind and it was hard to attract
investment in the company but we've
since we've just been able to solve that
problem and we've been able to show that
there's a great opportunity here and
we've been able to raise quite a bit of
capital to date and that's allowed us to
invest aggressively in things that I
think will help us over the long term
[Music]
ultimately I think the most important
determinant of success is perseverance
more than anything I think if you stick
to what you're trying to do instead of
course you're more likely to succeed
than if you try to do anything else
every time I hear a story is about how
chipper has been a positive impact to
someone in someone's life that's a
reminder to me that uh that story is
important and justifies all the pain
that we've gone through to get the
company to where it's at today
[Music]
thank you